Hey, David, are you.
Now ready to talk about who Joe Biden will
likely select as his vise presidential running
mate.
Yes, I am.
I've made it a point not to put the cart before
the horse.
So back in 2017 and 2018, before the midterms,
people would say, what are you thinking about
Democratic primary presidential candidates?
And I said, I'm thinking about the midterm.
I'll talk about that later when we still had
a primary going on.
People would call into the show or ask me
during livestreams.
Who do you see as the best running mate for
whoever is the nominee?
And we didn't know who the nominee was going
to be.
And I said, let's take it one step at a time.
So I'm going to answer the question as it's
asked, which is who do I
believe is likely?
I think right now the top three possibilities
for Joe Biden, given that he said he would
be selecting that he would be selecting a
woman as his running mate would be in no particular
order.
Kamala Harris, Amy Klobuchar and I would like
to think Elizabeth Warren now I've read conflicting
things about the likelihood of a possible
Warren running mate selection.
And a number of opinions are she would be
likely to be doing something in Biden's administration,
but not V.P.
We've heard about Warren possibly as treasury
secretary.
That would be quite a change from Stephen
Manoogian.
We've heard about Warren possibly as secretary
of state.
A lot is being floated around.
So in no particular order, I think the most
likely or Carmela, Warren and Amy.
Now, that being said, there's some other interesting
names that are that are increasingly being
discussed.
Gretchen Whitmer, the governor of Michigan,
is increasingly being being discussed.
Her response to Corona virus has been notable.
I don't know whether to call it good or bad.
You know, a lot of the responses that are
called really good are in states with a ton
of cases.
New York is an example.
Michigan is an example.
The argument would be, well, they'd be even
worse off if it weren't for these governors.
In any case, because Trump has been going
after her.
Gretchen Whitmer is very much in the public
eye.
Michelle Obama has been floated around.
I don't see it.
I just don't see it at all.
Stacey Abrams, who fell short of winning the
2018 Georgia gubernatorial election.
To Brian Kemp.
He was both running in that election and running
the election as secretary of state.
Interesting, right?
Stacey Abrams lost.
She's being mentioned as a possible Biden
running mate.
I would be shocked if it's Stacey Abrams.
It just doesn't feel like that's the direction
it's going.
And then a few people have e-mailed me saying
that Bernie surrogate Nina Turner should be
selected by Joe Biden.
I see zero chance of that.
I just don't see any way that that becomes
a reality.
Tammy Duckworth has been mentioned.
I think that would be an interesting pick,
although it seems less likely than Amy, Kamala,
maybe Warren.
And then also the ideas has been increasingly
floated.
Some people are talking about Andrew Cuomo,
governor of New York, should replace Biden
as the presidential candidate.
I don't see how you make that happen again
unless something incredibly serious happened
to Joe Biden.
I don't see that.
But the idea of drafting Cuomo as V.P., of
course, Biden would have to go back on having
said he was going to pick a woman.
I think that would look really bad.
And I don't see Biden doing it unless circumstances
that I can't even imagine come to fruition.
But that's been mentioned as well.
Abandon his call to select a woman and go
with Andrew Cuomo, very high favourability
and sort of in the public eye as a result
of his coronavirus handling.
Again, New York with a crazy amount of cases.
CUOMO Communicating well, communicating almost
daily and turning things around and getting
getting to the peak much faster than many
other states.
It's an idea.
It probably would be a helpful one in a vacuum.
But going back on his word about a female
running mate may have been a problem.
This
is why many people say you never want to commit
to any identity boxes being checked by your
candidate because then you're artificially
limiting yourself.
Biden's calculation was saying he would select
a woman, would help him more than it would
potentially limit his choices and do damage
in the future.
So if you said, David, you've got a bet.
Who is it going to be?
I. I'm leaning towards Kamala.
I'm leaning towards Kamala.
And this is not an endorsement of Kamala in
any way.
But if you said I have to bet on only one,
I would guess Kamala Harris, I think we will
soon know.
Biden letting Bernie know several weeks ago
that he was starting to vet vise presidential
candidates.
And we will all know very, very soon we have
it.
TER Tremendous.
I almost a mixed, terrific and tremendous
we have a tremendous bonus show for you today.
Two ways to get instant access to the bonus
show.
Become a member at joint Packman dot com or
become a patron at Patry on dot com slash
David Pakman show.
Both are instant, almost instant.
30 seconds.
OK, with mild computer familiarity.
And you will be able to check out my crazy
police related story that I told on the Monday
bonus show from this past week.
Don't miss it.
Join Packman dot com patry on dot com slash
David Pakman.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.